the new year has seen its first batch of
free games with gold but 2020 is just
getting started
we've got 11 more months to go if you're
an Xbox Live Gold member and want to
know what you can grab in February I've
got you covered
first up on Xbox one is TT Isle of Man
TT or tourist trophy is a motorcycle
racing series and this one is set on the
legendary island course you can zoom
along the nearly 40 mile long track and
set your best time or race against
others online and you can do that
whenever in February as TT will be
available to download all month long
things slowed down to a creep with Xbox
ones other game Call of Cthulhu this
adventure is based on the pen and paper
RPG of the same name and it follows
investigator Pearce as he looks into
strange events on Dark Water Island you
can solve the mystery for yourself and
download the game from February 16th
through March 15th on the 360 side you
can team up with friends to conquer
fable heroes this hack and slash
adventure lets four heroes fight
together or against each other in the
land of Albion both the competition and
co-op include familiar sights and fights
from the fable series you can download
heroes from February 1st through the
15th the last 360 game is actually a
backwards compatible original Xbox title
Star Wars Battlefront lets you fight
through the first six movies as the
Republic separatists Empire or rebels
just note that this version of the game
unfortunately does not include online
multiplayer still you can grab it from
February 16th through the 29th and
thanks to backwards compatibility both
this and fable heroes can be played on
Xbox one as well and those are your free
games with gold for February 20 20
remaining and reviews for these titles
on GameSpot and stay tuned as we report
on the new games with gold lineup every
month
[Music]